madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir un
chinois à washington en janvier et ce
sera monsieur thank you ping le numéro 2
chinois à l'américain à pékin en mai ou
en juin
et ce sera le président jimmy carter six
ans après le voyage surprise de richard
nixon simons et tongs c'est donc une
nouvelle page historique qu'américains
et chinois viennent de tourner pour les
états unis il n'y a plus désormais
qu'une seule chine
celle de pékin et c'est avec cette chine
que washington aura désormais des
relations diplomatiques fini la fiction
d'une chine historique qui représentait
dès 1949 par formose pour les etats unis
c'est l'heure du réalisme politique et
économique pékin 800 millions de
consommateurs pékin adversaire de
l'union soviétique est aussi une carte
importante taiwan ne pas compromettre
les négociations très avancées avec
moscou sur la limitation des armes
nucléaires
les accrocher la main tendue par pékin
depuis quelques mois
le moment était venu de passer aux actes
de reconnaître une réalité a dit
monsieur carter ce n'est pas l'événement
qui surprend mais la date à laquelle il
survient une semaine seulement avant la
rencontre à genève des ministres des
affaires étrangères américain et
soviétique moscou
constatant ainsi que la fameuse
stratégie tripolaire de messieurs
kissinger et nixon trouve aujourd'hui
son application et sur un autre plan les
états unis n'abandonneront pas
totalement les 17 millions d'habitants
de taïwan ils continueront à leur livrer
des armes défensives
ce qui fait grincer pékin mais l'accord
était à ce prix car taiwan reste pour
l'amérique le symbole de la lutte
anticommuniste
enfin et surtout il y à pékin qui ouvre
un oeil sur le monde le japon la france
l'allemagne avec lesquels des accords
commerciaux très importants viennent
d'être signés et entre le beurre et les
canons chinois et américains ont fait
leur choix avec un marché de 800
millions d'habitants les états unis
veulent devenir derrière le japon mais
devant l'europe
le principal partenaire de la chine le
président carter et ses conseillers ont
choisi la politique du réel qui s'appuie
sur les intérêts économiques pour
neutraliser les arsenaux militaires
tel est le contenu du message transmis
par washington et pékin à moscou en
corée au japon à singapour en australie
et même au vietnam la décision du
président carter a reçu un accueil
favorable accueil favorable aussi dans
tous les pays occidentaux et notamment à
paris où même si aucun commentaire
officiel n'a été encore publier cette
évolution est jugé avec satisfaction
à moscou l'agencé officielle tassé
contenter dans un premier temps
d'annoncer la nouvelle sans commentaire
dans un deuxième temps l'agencé tass a
développé son information en insistant
toutefois essentiellement sur le
maintien des liens même s'ils sont plus
large qu'avant entre washington et
taiwan taiwan où la nouvelle a causé une
intense surprise et surtout une vive
inquiétude l'armée a été mise en état d'
alerte
de nombreuses manifestations se sont
déroulées devant la statue de tchang
kaï-chek et sur le plan politique le
premier ministre et le ministre des
affaires étrangères de taiwan ont
présenté leur démission celle du
ministre des affaires étrangères a
d'ailleurs été aussitôt acceptée 1949
mao tsé toung s'installe à pékin battu
le général chiang kai shek est obligé de
se réfugier à formose avec l'aide
américaine il va transformer cette île
en une véritable forteresse for most
fait partie du bouclier américain anti
communiste en asie et c'est le seul
gouvernement chinois reconnus par
washington pour que le réalisme
politiques l'emportent il faudra
attendre la visite du président nixon à
pékin en février 1972 23 ans d'absence
rompu par cette poignée de main entre
nixon échoue en live show en live le
fidèle premier ministe de mao tsé toung
qui avait tout fait sur le plan
diplomatique pour préparer cette
réconciliation
c'est aussi le début de l'abandon de
formose puisque le communiqué de
shanghai reconnaît que formose fait
partie intégrante de la chine
signe de cette détente les américains
obtiennent la libération de deux pilotes
abattus au dessus de la chine pendant la
guerre du vietnam
monsieur kissinger et le diplomate
américain qui voyagent le plus en chine
c'est lui qui a préparé la rencontre
nixon mao en 1975 il accompagne le
président ford à pékin où il retrouve un
mao tsé toung très diminuée un an plus
tard
mao tsé toung moeurs
à l'âge de 83 ans malgré les difficultés
de succession le nouvel homme fort de la
chine le président hu wang va poursuivre
dans ce domaine la politique de mao tsé
toung qui amènera donc à cette ouverture
alors georges courteline il faut
remarquer surtout aujourd'hui le peu de
commentaires faits dans la journée à
moscou
et encore des commentaires qui ne montre
pas disons une satisfaction exagéré mais
aucune raison d'illuminer les tours du
kremlin
en fait il ya une énorme lutte
d'influencé nazis et cette lutte pour la
suprématie ses joues en fait maintenant
à 1 contre 3 il ya d'un côté l'urss qui
est seul ou presque tout seul et de
l'autre côté ils sont trois il ya la
chine le japon et les états unis et sur
ses 3 il y en a deux qui ont un
dynamisme économique fantastique c'est à
dire le japon les états-unis bien
entendu l'appareil
la partie est donc forcément inégal ont
choisi vous me direz l'urss garde des
pions il ya le vietnam qui est la fidèle
sentinelles des soviétiques en asie du
sud est
mais de quel poids pèse le petit vietnam
à côté de l'industrie japonaise par
exemple la route et des 900 millions de
chinois monsieur jaber six ans après le
voyage déjà historique de monsieur
richard nixon à pékin c'est un nouvel
événement qui s'est produit hier dans
ses relations entre washington et pékin
finalement à votre avis est-ce que la
carte du monde risque d'être changée
dans les mois qui viennent je vous dis
reste un événement qu'on a vu monter
lentement à l'horizon la visite les
échanges des équipes de ping pong
c'était en 1971 c'est à dire il ya déjà
sept ans mais c'est un évènement
considérable que les russes ont
d'ailleurs
favoriser maladroitement en laissant le
japon conclure avec chine un accord qui
a retourné toutes les positions
aujourd'hui c'est très important parce
que nous devons nous français et
européens nous interroger sur les
conséquences de tout cela
alors est ce que vous pensez monsieur
joubert que les russes placés devant
cette situation vraiment défavorable
pour eux on faire une bêtise qui vont
risquer de provoquer un conflit pour
sortir de cette espèce de situation un
contre trois mois je ne crois guère au
betis et russes comme vous dites
monsieur porte si vous les connaissez
bien
non je crois pas à cela je crois que ce
sont des gens qui vont sentir se sont
resserrés autour de 1 neto qu'ils ont
contribué à monter d'ailleurs et qu'ils
vont chercher à faire bouger d'autres
pièces et c'est là où la faire nous
intéresse même par rapport à notre
politique actuelle française et
européenne
je crois que les russes vont à la suite
de cette affaire d'extrême orient se
tourner davantage vers l'allemagne
je dirais vers les deux allemagnes est
envisagée avec quelque chose qui est
dans la perspective de l'allemagne qui
est l'unité du peuple allemand qui est
une chose fondamentale dont les
allemands voulaient dire que les
soviétiques donnerait la possibilité aux
allemands de se réunifier qui n'ont plus
depuis la guerre contre contre la
neutralité de l'allemagne bien entendu
c'est à dire la sortie de leur portier
de l'allemagne occidentale pratiquement
de l'europe dès 9hoo bientôt dehors des
douze je dis qu'on ne peut pas jouer les
deux politiques
et si la politique allemande répond même
un peu à cet appel
on l'a sentira moins présentes en europe
et ceux ci tombent dans une époque qui
en effet d'une époque où la sphère
européenne
et poser de façon souvent importantes ou
minable mais veut dire qu'il ya une
donnée nouvelle depuis les airs alors
dans ce cas le coup porté l'union
soviétique par les états unis et les
chinois se traduire aussi par un coup
sévère porté l'unification européenne
oui certainement certainement ils n'ont
pas fait que les tout cela probablement
ou en tout cas ils pensent que
l'allemagne tiendra mais je ne vois pas
quel est l'homme politique allemand
l'homme public allemand à qui on
proposera la réunification et qui y fera
la fine bouche la refusera alors si les
reds jouent cette partie ils vont
embarrassé beaucoup d'états et beaucoup
de nos politiques je les remercie
l'accord américano chinois qui est le
meilleure illustration en tout cas d'une
volonté de détente dans le monde un
événement sur lequel nous reviendrons
d'ailleurs lundi soir dans notre édition
spéciale notre émission même spéciale
consacrée à la paix dans le monde
une émission spéciale consacrée à la
paix qui se prépare activement et qui
vous sera présenté par jean-pierre
elkabbach sur une réalisation de roger
benhamou trois heures de documents de
témoignages réunis par tous les
reporters d'antenne 2 dans le monde
entier puis sur notre plateau raymond
devos georges brassens mitis theodorakis
maurice béjart j'en oublie bien sûr
beaucoup d'autres une intervention en
direct aussi de monsieur marché dyan le
ministre des affaires étrangères
d'israël et pour la première fois en
force des images de low cost ce
feuilleton américain consacré aux
méfaits du nazisme que vous pourrez voir
sur en pays au début de l'année la paix
donc lundi soir 20h30 sur antenne
c'est fini village de la répétition qui
ont eu lieu ce qui est vieux chais après
midi sur le plateau du journal d'antenne
2 amis c'est ça monsieur georges
marchais ne tient pas à rencontrer
monsieur françois mitterrand ni monsieur
michel crépeau d'ailleurs des rencontres
au sommet il y en a eu pendant des
années et ça a conduit à ce qu'un jour
willows qu'au jour ils l'ont voulu ils
ont brisé l'union c'est ce qu'a déclaré
très exactement aujourd'hui le numéro un
communiste en réponse à la proposition
de monsieur françois mitterrand de
réunir prochainement le comité de
liaison de la gauche
le crs n'est aussi une réunion
aujourd'hui il la tiendra encore demain
pour la minorité du parti socialiste il
s'agit de savoir si l'unité règne encore
au sein de cette tendance sur les grands
thèmes politiques a développé et pour
l'instant deux courants s'affrontent
alors le crs va-t-il éclaté entre les
partisans d'une ligne favorable à
l'union avec les communistes et les
militants proches de monsieur michel
rocard pour monsieur georges sarre l'un
des membres fondateurs du crs le débat
doit absolument être tranché et ce dès
demain pense qu'il n'y a pas de ligne
politique possible et fouette d'une
hypocrisie formidable pour plaindre les
travailleurs pour regretter la montée du
chômage et en même temps ne pas lutter
contre l'actuelle division
internationale du travail
ne pas lutter contre la liquidation de
branches entières de nos industries
contre la disparition ou la mort de
régions entières
il faut donc être conséquent et les
militants du crs sont des militants
socialistes sérieux c'est à dire qu'ils
veulent que leur ligne leur pratique ait
ensemble et quand il défend des
travailleurs ils leur promettent en même
temps au projet qui leur permettent de
sortir de la situation
mais vous êtes déjà la minorité du parti
socialiste alors si vous divisez encore
qu'est ce qui va rester
vous savez vous partie ce sujet il n'y a
plus de maison et il n'y a plus de
minorité
il y a des gens qui sont en train de
débats démocratiquement pour essayer de
se mettre d'accord sur le moyen
d'approfondir la ligne d'épinés s'était
dit faire en sorte que la gauche gagne
la prochaine fois pour effectivement
changer la vie janvier l'associé donc
demain un éclatement du crs
logiquement je ne pense pas je souhaite
en tout cas une clarification il n'y
aurait rien de plus mauvais et de plus
faux que de maintenir autour du nid
politique des gens qui parlerait ils ont
un langage différent
enfin dernière image de cette journée
des hommes politiques français celle de
monsieur raymond barre mais pour une
fois le premier ministre n'a pas parlé
politique solide par vous constatez ne
s'y prêtait pas sous un chapiteau dressé
non loin de l'héliport de paris monsieur
raymond barre président est en effet le
noël des enfants du personnel de l'hôtel
matignon
un peu de détente donc pour le premier
ministre au moment où les pays
producteurs de pétrole se réunissent
pour fixer le prix du pétrole l'opep est
réuni à abou dhabi la séance
d'aujourd'hui ne s'est pas terminée sur
une décision concrète mais il semble
qu'un accord soit maintenant vu la
hausse des produits pétroliers ne
devrait pas être inférieur à 5% en
belgique c'est la veillée d'armes demain
les électeurs iront aux urnes pour
renouveler le parlement
la participation sera importante il est
vrai que les belges ne peuvent se
réfugier dans l'abstention le vote chez
eux est obligatoire une fois élus les
chambres devront procéder à une révision
importante de la constitution réforme
qui devrait faire de la belgique un état
fédéral n'était pas obligatoire il y
aurait probablement demain plus de 50%
d'abstention et c'est ce que tous les
observateurs politiques belges
s'accordent à reconnaître les belges
pour l'instant sont beaucoup plus
préoccupés de la préparation des fêtes
de fin d'année pourquoi cette
désaffection est bien parce que les
belges ont déjà voté l'année dernière
pour renouveler leurs deux assemblées et
ils sont d'abord et avant tout
semble-t-il
lassé de ces jeux politiques de cette
politique politicienne comme il
l'appelle
pourtant l'enjeu de ce vote engage
l'avenir du pays il s'agira pour les
nouveaux parlementaires de définir le
mode de relation entre wallons et
flamands
le fédéralisme la poursuite de la
régionalisation déjà entamés en tout cas
un enjeu dont l'actuel premier ministre
n'a pas manqué de souligner l'importance
en réunissant la presse à l'issue du
dernier conseil
quand le voeu des missions est la règle
j'irai présentée au roi la démission du
gouvernement
la seule chose que je puis dire ce que
j'ai le sentiment que la période qui
vient de s'écouler
mettez pas la plus difficile sera sans
doute un des scrutins les plus
importants de ces dernières années parce
que le lecteur rôle qua non seulement
entre une autre société mais aussi une
deux formes de belgique si vous voulez
choix de société parce que la belgique
est toujours en crise économique et
sociale et du scrutin dépendra peut-être
les solutions apportées à cette crise et
puis choix de belgique parce qu'il ya
toujours nos problèmes communautaires et
certains diront d'ailleurs que le choix
société influencera le choix aussi de
belgique
quelle sera la future assemblée le parti
socialiste risque de perdre du terrain
surtout en wallonie où on va mesurer les
effets de la crise sidérurgique partout
ailleurs et sociaux chrétiens le cvp en
flandre sont assurés du succès de toute
façon le futur gouvernement sera social
chrétien mais ce sont les électeurs qui
imposeront les priorités résultats
demain une nouvelle greffe du coeur a
été réalisée hier soir à lyon dans le
service de cardiologie du professeur
marion le receveur est un homme âgé de
57 ans aucun renseignement n'a été
fournie sur la personne dont le coeur a
été prélevé pour être greffés cette
opération est la quatrième de ce type
réalisée à lyon depuis le début de
l'année 78 un formidable match de rugby
voilà ce que retiendront tous ceux qui
cet après-midi ont suivi dans les jeux
du stade sur antenne de la rencontre
all-blacks barbarians formidable match
qui a vu les néo zélandais l'emporter à
la dernière minute 18 points à 16
un vrai régal
ce match des all blacks contre les
barbarians en maillot cerclé sur la
pelouse de l'arms park de cardiff d'un
très grand moment de rugby en première
mi temps ce sont les néo zélandais qui
imposent leur jeu plus collectif
domination concrétisée à la 23e minute
par un essai collectif qui sera
finalement attribué au pilier johnston
il sera pas transformé 4 à 0 pour les
all blacks
un quart d'heure plus tard les barbares
y en ce moment à trouver une homogénéité
ses joueurs venus d'irlande des causes
de gaz d'angleterre et de france jean
piat vivait jantes occupée la veille
étaient en effet invités à se joindre à
cette prestigieuse équipe ont joué égal
avec cette formidable machine à jouer le
rugby que sont les all blacks ils
égalisent grâce à l'ailier cmn auteur
d'une remarquable partie le score est
maintenant de 4 à cas au début de la
deuxième mi temps alors que le score est
à 7 à 7 après une pénalité de mckechnie
pour les blacks et de bennett pour les
bars variance le pressing des néo
zélandais se fait plus intense dans tous
les compartiments du jeu ils font preuve
d'une très grande méprise que ce soit
les lignes d'avants très puissante et
trois quarts ni présent où les lignes
arrières très rapidement en action
qualité de jeu concrétisée par deux
essais à la 47e minute
on se croit car elle reflète ch 11 7
pour les blacks
et à la 52e minute après une mêlée près
des poteaux des barbares y ans gars
grâce à williams on aura 15 à 7 pour les
blacks
et c'est alors les choses semblent
entendu compte à la 65e minute
klemen pour les barbarians après une
passe de skréla vient marquer en coin le
ne transforme 15 à 13 à la 73e minute
une pénalité réussie par bennett
permettent aux barbarians de mener 16 à
mais c'est à la dernière minute de la
partie que donne réussit un drop qui
donne la victoire aux néo zélandais
résultat final 18 à série
en football cet après midi ce soir et
demain après midi pour le compte du
championnat de france on jouera cet
après midi strasbourg a battu metz 2 but
à 1
cinq autres matches auront lieu ce soir
et 4 demain donc parmi ses quatre
derniers matches un meurtrier duel
parisien qui opposera le paris football
club et le paris saint-germain deux
clubs qui sont actuellement bien mal
classés et puis n'oublions pas tous ceux
ils seront au total près de 35000 qui
ont couru aujourd'hui où vont courir
demain au bois de boulogne
le traditionnel cross du figaro remporte
cette année encore un immense succès
regardez ils sont fous fous de course à
pied tous atteint d'un virus qui assure
une santé d'acier et procure une joie
intérieure que tôt ou tard souhaitons le
vous partagerez aussi au bois de
boulogne à paris nous sommes vous êtes
ils sont 35 milles au départ du figaro
l'épreuve reine de la course à pied pour
qu aujourd'hui ajouter aux militaires et
à quelques têtes connues
ce sont des familles entières qui
prennent le départ du figaro
l'éventail s'étend des vieilles pointes
courant allègrement vers leurs 80
printemps puisque à leurs petits-enfants
le prof du figaro c'est peut-être
l'exploit de bousculer ou pour perdre
les deux mains dans les poches des
astuces et avant tout la pure foulée des
trans amis anonymes qui se font mal par
plaisir
il fait souvent par yann moix est un
éminent 35 mille participants au cross
du figaro parmi eux combien d'adeptes de
cette mode qui nous vient d'amérique le
jogging on peut toutefois comme le fait
aujourd'hui le figaro littéraire se
poser la question qu'est ce qui fait
donc courir les français simon figaro
littéraire ne veut pas tomber bien
gérard holtz a essayé de répondre pour
nous sur le pipeline
made in you essai traduisez plus
simplement cela vient d'amérique c'est
le jogging le footing
bref tout simplement la course à pied
que l'on fait en petites foulées
n'importe où dans les rues dans les
parcs dans les jardins publics et à
n'importe quel moment ou presque plus de
15 millions d'américains sont devenus en
quelques mois des adeptes de ce sport
une pratique en fait vieille comme le
monde
souvenez-vous de marathon mais une
pratique qui aujourd'hui devient un
véritable phénomène social
et puis quelques années après l'amérique
comme souvent les français eux aussi
maintenant se mettre à courir
alors pourquoi et bien tout simplement
pour le plaisir pour faire un peu de
sport pour garder la forme ou pour la
retrouver
toutes les explications sur rejoignent
et il est vrai qu'en prenant un minimum
de précaution tous les médecins
pratiquement son cours le jogging alors
quels sont les bienfaits de la course à
pied sont multi mais en premier il faut
passer par l'organe essentiel qui est le
coeur et également avec le coeur les
poumons
les deux vont ensemble et permettent
d'amener l'oxygène aux muscles ce qui
est le plus important pour faire un
effort de longue durée et donc pour être
en bonne condition physique
on dit aussi que ça fait maigrir ah ça
c'est évident en courant en consomment
des calories on utilise la grèce en
utilisent des glucides et cette façon on
perd du poids alors qu'elles sont
maintenant les méfaits de ce sport il
existe aussi
et ça c'est surtout au niveau de la
prévention qu'on peut éviter ces méfaits
se situe surtout au niveau des tendons
particulier lorsqu'elle est trop de
morphologiques que la statique s'est dit
au niveau des pieds au niveau des
membres inférieurs il faut corriger ces
troubles et ainsi on envie on évitera
certainement l'apparition des tendinites
qui sont un peu la rançon de la bogue
actuelle dujogging en fait une bonne
méthode pour être en forme
certainement c'est meilleur que tous les
médicaments et aucun médicament qui peut
permettre à l'organisme de rester en
forme de cette façon
tout le monde peut faire du jogging
hommes ou femmes quel que soit l'âge ou
le milieu il suffit d'avoir une bonne
paire de chaussures un survêtement un
maillot et surtout l' envie de se
défouler en courant les premiers pas
parfois vers un véritable entraînement
de sportif
voici d'ailleurs le pignon d'un ancien
champion d'athlétisme au g20 but qu'est
ce que vous pensez du jogging de cette
course à pied dans la ville
moi je pense que c'est une très bonne
chose parce que ça permet aux gens de
mener une activité physique qu'ils
soient à leur portée à leur rythme
surtout sans rechercher de performance
de compétition et c'est une merveilleuse
introduction à l'athlétisme merveilleuse
introduction à la connaissance du sport
aux états unis sa fille très très bien
pris ça s'est développé ruines d'une
manière extravagante
ici aucune raison que ça ne prenne pas
les français sont pas plus plus plus
paresseux que les autres ils sont pas
plus fermes et non plus à ce qui leur
est nécessaire parce que en fait une
activité sportive comme celle là si
nécessaire
après tout les stress de la vie moderne
ces jolis seins
il ya quelques années un coureur en
survêtement zigzaguant dans les
embouteillages cela faisait sourire on
n'hésitait pas à s'en moquer parfois
aujourd'hui les choses ont évolué le
joggeur passe inaperçu il fait partie du
spectacle de la ville comme les piétons
les deux roues les automobiles et même
les accidents
bien sûr il ya la pollution les gaz
d'échappement mais à tout prendre disent
les spécialistes
il vaut mieux courir en respirant de
l'air pollué que de ne pas courir du
tout alors 36 mille concurrents pour le
seul cross du figaro des fabricants
d'articles de sport qui voient leurs
chiffres de ventes grimper des livres
des gadgets des bijoux même ont
l'honneur de la course à pied décidément
le jogging est à la mode
si cela vous tente c'est facile le stade
c'est votre ville
parce que je sais gérard court toujours
avant de terminer en chansons devraient
une nouvelle insolite pour la première
fois le parc des expositions de la porte
de versailles abrite la grande braderie
de paris à la veille des fêtes le plus
grand salon européen de soldes restera
ouvert de match qu'à 22h et puis la plus
grande star de tous les temps mickey a
été vendu aux enchères
en réalité ce sont des figurines du
premier petit personnage de walt disney
qui ont été vendus à paris écoutez bien
un petit mickey en velours pas plus de
30 centimètres mais datant des années 30
atteint la cote de 6000 francs
la météo pour demain le temps va se
refroidir sur l'ensemble du pays avec
des gelées encore assez faible sur le
nord-est
le ciel sera variable avec des averses
locales et des chutes de neige même à
faible altitude
le vent soufflera assez fort près des
côtes mais je vous ai promis une chanson
pour terminer cette édition demain et
lundi l'a examiné lice sera à paris elle
donnera deux récitals dans ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler un grand music hall de
la rive droite l'olympia pour ne pas le
citer deux récitals seulement vous ne
pourrez donc tous l'écouté alors ce soir
je vous propose en avant première un
extrait de la répétition du spectacle
qui sera donné demain et lundi l'a
examiné lee cabaret bonne soirée à tous
mako décédé en ligne au boom
nos vies changent quand tous de calais
faute à la mairie comme vocal blouse et
sabots en vendée
this time
hubert
faire comme moi
épisode
à
non
j'suis voisine voiture washington sports
network licra
hélas
la famille
tu me lâches misé gros salaire minimum
c'est clair si tu veux faire une idée
en petite vie
good things envahissant
vous y croyez
chaud
crim
la seconde
m
même un à offre une chance
à
cette semaine
malbon masset